crowds turned out in Tehran to give
foreign minister mohammad javad zarif a
hero's welcome as he arrived back from
Switzerland many of them were young the
younger generation has been hit
especially hard by years of economic
crisis the lifting of sanctions could
make life much easier but Isabella's
daddy I'm here to welcome mr. Zarif to
thank him for the great job he did and
the big favor he did us he tried to make
up for the 10 years of our lives that
were lost out on dating me on Silas amor
had off he had a framework agreement was
reached after eight days of talks
details will be worked out by the end of
june Iran has promised to reduce its
uranium enrichment capacities by
two-thirds it's also subjecting itself
to strict international oversight for 25
years by the UN nuclear watchdog the
IAEA in return many of the sanctions on
Iran will be eased or lifted the Iranian
president said the framework agreement
would help relax tensions with a number
of other countries Iran bovada Hajj am
ahad if the opposite side meets its
promises then Iran will too if one day
they wish to choose a different path
than our nation will also have options
open to it boss Fahad boot at Friday
prayers a senior cleric personally thank
the Foreign Minister a strong sign that
surive still enjoys the support of the
country's religious leaders